kim kardashian is opening up about the
epiphany that she says caused her
divorce from kanye west you just gotta
roll with it the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder covers the march issue of vogue
and inside she says that for so long she
did what made other people happy but in
the last two years she decided to put
herself first why not quote that feels
really good and even if that created
changes and caused my divorce i think
it's important to be honest with
yourself about what really makes you
happy i've chosen myself i think it's
okay to choose you at the end of the day
life is about being happy
of course kim filed for divorce from the
grammy winner last year after six years
of marriage
and now the skim's founder says her 40s
are all about being on team kim i'm
going to work out i'm going to have more
fun spend more time with my kids and the
people who make me happy i'm going to
put my phone down
it is what it is as for co-parenting
their four children north saint chicago
and psalm kim says it's all about
keeping it positive you could be so hurt
or angry at your ex but i think in front
of the kids it always has to be your
dad's the best make sure you are your
co-parents biggest cheerleader no matter
what you're personally going through all
that echoes what kim's sister chloe told
et back in 2019 about the good example
their own parents set after divorcing
it's hard work for all parties i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
as for kanye well he responded to kim's
vogue spread on wednesday morning
posting a collage of images of kim and
their kids from the shoot and writing
quote god please bring our family back
together just do something for my heart
of course kim is now dating saturday
night live star pete davidson while
kanye has been spotted packing on the
pda with uncut gems actress julia fox
but according to a source the 44 year
old rapper still has hope that he and
kim will get back together it's a
sentiment he expressed live on stage in
december when he changed the lyrics to
his hit run away
[Music]
and while the reality star didn't
directly mention pete in her vogue
interview she did reference that bahamas
trip they took right after the new year
saying that the people she was on
vacation with threw their phones in the
ocean a reminder to live in and enjoy
the present i love that that energy in
my life and when it comes to kim's
relationship with fashion now that she's
no longer with the yeezy designer she
explains why it's now a bit
nerve-racking i think kim is one of if
not the most influential woman in
fashion
there's something scary about being out
there on your own but also something so
liberating who knows i might just be in
skims and be so comfy and casual and
wear no makeup and that might be what i
feel like representing to the world
maybe it's just not that serious
[Music]